the decision to search the home of a
former president was unprecedented the
decision to unseal the affidavit which
led to the operation highly unusual
21 of the 38 pages have been heavily
redacted to protect witnesses and the
integrity of the investigation
the affidavit reveals that of 184
documents handed over from mar-a-lago
last january 25 were marked top secret
and they suspected there were more
mar-a-lago
is the furthest thing from a secure
facility dennis after gut a former
federal prosecutor said keeping
documents there could have caused great
harm among them are
documents marked
hcs which means
human intelligence sources
that can be
uh
american
foreign intelligence
assets undercover in foreign countries
whose
disclosure could easily result in them
being killed how would you anticipate
president trump's legal team responding
to what has been revealed today is
apparent strategy in what he has filed
previously has been
the political approach
not the legal approach
the legal approach would be
keep
your mouth
shut
president trump described the document
as a total public relations subterfuge
by the fbi and the department of justice
in a pre-recorded interview just
released he continues to claim the
search of his home was politically
motivated
they brought many many fbi agents in all
right before the midterms
and all when i have the best poll
numbers i've ever had this is a
political attack on our country
despite the redactions this document
does shed more light on the
investigation into claims president
trump mishandled classified information
by taking documents with him when he
left the white house the department of
justice says the facts of this case are
particularly compelling and it acted
because it was concerned steps may be
taken to frustrate the investigation
with the fbi under threat and the
political temperature continuing to rise
authorities really must feel they have a
case worth pursuing david blevins sky
news in washington